you know the the biggest thing in cyber
security uh or the next big thing in
cyber security back then
was uh if you think about the war the
digital aspect of the world right
everything is connected and if you look
at uh there is an interesting result
that shows that
83 of the internet traffic
is api traffic welcome to 20 minute
leaders
just sit back relax and learn from the
leaders of today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
this episode is powered by jventures a
community driven vc funded in silicon
valley
in partnership with lomi tech and
sponsored by hippo insurance
touring opposed labs and hillel hello
stanford i hope you're ready for an
awesome entrepreneurial story because
this one is just not going to disappoint
meet ruil yahoo co-founder and ceo at
salt security
rey is a former elite cyber security
unit veteran that led development of
high-end security systems
to protect the largest network in israel
of the idf
and the government he went to lead
development of security system projects
at
saigo digital systems a military-grade
security systems company
acquired by mellanox after cycle digital
systems
roy founded the cyber security college
that trains the next generation of
leaders and prepares them for serving
the idf's elite security units
welcome to 20 minute leaders how are you
i'm doing great how about yourself i'm
i'm doing fine as well thank you where
are you calling from right now
so right now i'm in actually in tel aviv
typically i'm in palo alto but because
of kobe du riley reasons i'm currently
in tel aviv
well it's a it's a great it's beautiful
weather outside where just the sun is
going to be setting
while we speak and so we might not be
too far away from each other
and we're going to talk about you know
this crazy journey that you're on
uh as a sick as a cyber security
engineer
in the idf understanding that there's a
gap in the market
making an interesting trip to silicon
valley and
making it a with some of the most
incredible investors
and some of the most incredible
accelerators like white combinator up to
today and i'm really excited to hear you
about your journey but i'm also excited
to hear about the cyber security
space in general and how you perceive it
and what your specific thesis is
around this industry so take me back to
your army days well what gets you
excited about cyber specifically why
cyber
yeah so i don't think cyber was really
uh
a choice i'll do say that i i started
programming
when i was very young i started
programming when i was nine
and i started to do a lot of freelance
work and all of things like that in the
age of 11 12
throughout my high school years and i
and i did a lot of things also in cyber
obviously it wasn't really advanced
stuff back then but right hacking stuff
building stuff website monetization
right a lot of like
an entrepreneurship uh activity i didn't
know it's like entrepreneurship right
but
like kind of building websites trying to
monetize them right doing a lot of
activities
and one of the experiences i think in
cyber that one day
um what happened is that
uh i don't remember exactly the
situation but i was talking
online some chat or something when i was
like 14 or 13
and uh someone said to me
hey uh you know i can control your
computer or something like that and you
suddenly
open the disk uh tray
and i was like whoa like where is this
uh coming from
and realizing that the game that was
sent to me you know
uh a few days back uh was
like an actual trojan horse and and all
that and kind of started to explode that
and it was
it kind of fascinated me how how with
the power of
of cyber security you know of cyber
attacks
so it got me very interested in uh
naturally you know
um in the army uh
you know the the elite technology units
definitely
you know where we will we our excel is
cyber right so
i got accepted to one of the best uh
sound security units and there
you know i i fell in love in south korea
even more
wow and so you're you're spending your
time in the idf you're
becoming more and more acquainted with
the space walk me through the end what
happens in the end that makes you say
sorry what happens in the end it makes
you say wow
there is an opportunity here outside of
the idf in the real world
yeah so i'll tell you up front that um i
always knew that i'm gonna start
something
like it's for me wasn't even a choice it
wasn't even a thought
like should i do that should i work
somewhere
like it's it was there was not even a
question you know
looking backwards it seems almost crazy
what i did back then and
flying over to the valley without any
investors spending all my money
you know looking backwards like uh wait
wait wait wait you're just you're
brushing off of this crazy crazy thing
go back it's it's not very common for
somebody from the other side of the
world
to just make that trip to silicon valley
waste all their money without any
investors so what what is actually
happening there
so what happens is that post army i had
uh
and another initiative uh in the cyber
security space not a startup what was in
cyber security kind of college and
courses to help
people uh kind of get accepted to to the
to the elite south security units
uh but you know uh while looking at the
api space and kind of when kind of
studying
uh salt or starting to you know validate
the idea
and and realizing that you know i'll
talk about it in a second how big
our apis are taking over the world by
being the huge attack vectors that
nobody talks about
um i decided to fly over to to the us to
the silicon valley and
i had no investors you know no money
really
so he was basically flying over um doing
like an air
bed and breakfast that literally
sleeping with an air bag
uh or like a sleeping bag on the floor
uh
because it was very extensive as you
know to be in palo alto and
when you don't have a lot of money just
you know like two years after release
from the army
uh and uh so i find like a place in like
that cost me like 300 bucks a month or
so
so try to understand what was the setup
like a house with like 12 different
people
in it and sleeping on the floor but just
for start to
meet with potential customers uh you
know potential investors i had no
network back then so
i came over i had a few meetings from
some alumni from the unit but
i was not really connected um i was 22
not really connected and uh
i started to uh expand my network
so you know i i was joining a
icon network so if you're familiar with
them the nonprofit org to help
israeli startups yes
yes that by the way she's also she's
probably one of our first investors in
the company
um and because yeah because we came to
the
the space and you know working 2 a.m 3
a.m like every day and she was looking
at us like wow
that's amazing and then she's like i
want to i want to invest i see your
determination
you know it seems like you're doing
something here really great
um and i then uh you know we started to
i started to attend events started to
meet people
socialize right and and for one people
to another intro and another
introduction another interaction and
suddenly
you know if i move fury's forward you
know two even three years forward
you know suddenly i know probably every
investors in the silicon valley every vc
have a partner
right most of them and kind of have a
very deep network
uh stunning from scratch absolute
scratch um
so what would be your big advice for
people that you know might not
might not have the privilege and
opportunity to to know people in silicon
valley or
or in any tech city in the world and
obviously there's
billions of people around the world that
don't have
access to to these to these you know
ecosystems
what do you do what do you do when you
land in a place that you're unfamiliar
with speaking a little bit of a
different language a different culture
and how do you bring yourself to a
position where within a year or two
you literally reinvent yourself as a as
a focal point
within it within the tech ecosystem in
silicon valley
i i think it's uh first of all not to be
afraid of that
uh at all like people suddenly give up
very quickly right i don't have these
connections i don't know if these
relationships
everybody build them right so i used to
go
to a lot of events right uh icon events
investor events whatever
startup even right and and network and
socialize
you know uh very aggressively so i will
not
sit there and talk with one or two
people
in the entire event i will go around and
i'll talk and develop a lot of
conversation tell them about what we do
and what's the idea what are we all
about about screen apis why this is a
super big thing and you know showing
obviously i'm really passionate about it
and then when people
see that they people naturally wants to
help others
right they see if you have good
intentions you have something there
they feel confident that you know you
obviously will not embarrass them right
it's it's like there's a real thing here
really unique
right and then like oh i know someone in
you know blah blah blah that i can
connect you with send me something and
i'll afford great
uh or some investors you meet and you
know
it and it's kind of you meet another
entrepreneurs and they have their own
investors and
suddenly it's exponentially going uh but
you need to work for it it will not come
by itself um so be proactive i would say
not reactive uh and if you are
passionate enough
and you have something behind its people
this productivity
what do when you say be proactive
obviously one can translate that for
being confident and going to events and
talking but
it must be more than that it must this
relationship building
must be more than just going and just
you know experiencing these events and
just talking to a bunch of people
so what is it that what are actually the
factors that would determine whether
you're successful
in in doing that or not
first of all everything starts with your
goals right
what you're looking to achieve i think
in the very beginning when you have
scratch everything is good because it's
good to know
people at companies like linkedin and
microsoft and whatever and it's good to
know
investors community it's good to know
other entrepreneurs i think
you know other entrepreneurs are
probably the best because they can
really relate to where you are
uh their work there as well so that's
helpful as well
to try to navigate um but but it's
what's your goals
let me give you an example my co-founder
michael nicosia
is you know originally italian born and
raised and uh
when he was 11 he moved to the u.s and
is living in the u.s in the last
you know several or probably decades in
the us in the silicon valley
and it's really unique right uh
co-founders though not both israelis
both technologies
and michael is like a huge vp of sales
marketing that was kind of
driving huge success and amazing exits
and when i started i thought wow i don't
know a lot about
enterprise sales inside of security and
um
i want to learn that uh a lot because
i'm going to sell to
fortune 500 type of companies uh you
know south security products i never did
this before
and um i i looked in all the israeli
successful startups and i looked who was
there
in the vp on the sales side like the
first kind of vp of cell that kind of
scaled the org
you are the sales leader in the cyber
community
and my call was top of my list i looked
at
he was an adolem that got uh acquired by
microsoft at the amazing exit he joined
them where
there were zero revenues and scaled them
to um
you know millions of millions of dollars
and hundreds customers plus and so on
and i looked and started to look okay
who do i know that knows him and i got
you know a few individuals that that
knew him um
that connected me with him and i met him
in the microsoft office after the
adolescent acquisition and
and i told him let me tell you what i
have in salt and and he was like wow
that's amazing and he connected through
a few csos that were custom lps
what they think and and very quickly we
we hit it off
super well and he joined me as being my
co-founder so
just as an example how you set certain
goal how you work backwards
how you find the connection you meet
someone and and bam you know i have the
most amazing co-founder in
in the world i i'm so inspired by
hearing you talk about your co-founder
this way and i wish for every
every person to talk about their
co-founder uh
in in any similar way i think it's just
so awesome roy
you're you're in the epicenter of cyber
security in 2021
the world is digitalized in a capacity
that
no one has ever expected at the rate
that it has a cyber security some people
are calling it a bubble i'm calling it a
really really really huge
ceiling level bubble that you know is
it's just infinite possibilities because
there are infinite possibilities for
attackers and therefore there are
infinite possibilities
for the defenders and so tell me a
little bit about your perspective as to
the cyber security market in general
and then let's dive deep into what
you're doing with salt security
yeah that's a great uh question so
in general i think as you as you said i
don't think cyber security is a bubble i
think definitely the cyber security
landscape is continuously expanding
and that's what you know proved to be
you know you see the cyber security
market growing every year continuously
and consistently uh through pandemic
through crisis
because companies cannot afford gaining
breach not even in pandemic time
i will do say there is a lot of noise in
cyber i think once there is a certain
trend
you see a lot of companies or a lot of
startups try to do something around it
or try to have some functionality
related to some trend
so there is a lot of noise and most
companies thinking
in silos versus thinking how they are
playing a role in an ecosystem
for a company and looking for a buyer
perspective um
so i think there is a lot of noise like
there is a true growth and there is true
need that continuously growing
but in the same time there is a lot of
noise
and when i looked at you know different
ideas in cyber the reason why we
decided on like we thought salt and
securing apis is the
biggest big thing you know the the
biggest thing in cyber security
uh or the next big thing in cyber
security back then
was uh if you think about the war the
digital aspect of the world right
everything is connected and if you look
at uh there is an interesting result
that shows that
83 of the internet traffic
is api traffic just think about it it's
the entire internet is api 83
look at our podcast right now or the
recording right it's an api based you go
to your
you don't zoom it's api based you pay
something go into your mobile app web
app it's api based
uh you have companies integrating
between each other right you go and
schedule appointment to the doctor's api
base they
fetch you know medical data from other
companies you have micro services
kubernetes moving into the cloud apis
are exploding
and all of our data all of our sensitive
data
and personal data is being exposed to
apis right
you pay with apis you buy with apis
you connect to your car with an api you
buy insurance with api and the trend
especially during kobe that everything
is becoming more and more digital
right so the more thing you should do
digital and not physical
without physical presence so the api
landscape is continuously expanding in
the attack surface
where solutions in the space as i looked
at them were designed for 20 years ago
internet or in applications so i i
thought wow that's
that's huge you know this is you know
the big is
you know when the file was created when
there was internet started
kind of i thought wow api are exactly
the next big thing
uh for for cyber security and for the
internet
take me five years down the line what is
it what is the grand vision where
where are we headed
so the game vision is and it takes me
five years uh i look even earlier the
grand vision is to
you know we are building here and not
very far away from it
a multi-billion dollar company that
providing a platform
uh for companies to be able to address
all of their
api and application security needs um
in a total kind of grand scheme of
things
we build our solution in a way that is
not
only to address specific use cases we
build the architecture in our big
database architecture in a way that will
allow us to expand continuously
to consolidate more and more needs and
use cases
towards our solutions so the customer
will not need to use
you know six different tools you will
need just to have salt
uh so we thought from the beginning we
had the mindset of
we are building something being here we
are not him going to do a fast exit you
know we passed on
a few m a's offered uh you know along
our journey we had a few m a offers
we passed on all those because we when
michael also joined me he told me
i'm not looking to do another all along
you know i did 320 million dollar exit
to the company it's great it's amazing
i'm looking to do something big and
that's our mindset so we are always
strategically thinking
what's the end goal right and how we're
building in uh
a company an enduring company that can
uh can consult they can build a platform
and not just a siloed
solution that will be sold for 300
million you know exit
i love that and i think that i need to
hear it more i think that a lot of
others need to hear this more this this
this just this vision and this you know
it's not even a vision about you know i
asked you about the vision of the
company
you didn't even take me about the vision
the the actual you know technology
you're taking me a vision of
what this company is going to be and as
a part of the ecosystem and i just love
that aspiration and i can't wait to see
where salt goes
i have a few fun questions are you ready
yeah go ahead all right number one what
was your favorite subject in school
k-12
um probably uh
i was in electronics in the last two
years and i built kind of robots and
uh and i think it was the best teacher i
ever had
so uh they told me you can build
whatever you want
just think about something i'll help you
to do that right and and i think it's
one of the things that open your mind to
you have no limits so i love that i love
it
all right and one of your role models in
life who do you look up to whether it's
a real or fictional
um wow that's actually a tricky question
because i think in
from different people i take different
things right not certainly i'm looking
for the whole package but
i love certain uh you know
uh southern people for specific things
uh i will say that
i think people i go back and watch all
of things i think steve jobs
has a lot of inspirational things i
think that his uh
his speech on stanford by the way right
uh
is probably one of the video i watched
the most most
most times and i think some combination
of elon musk that i think is also very
inspirational about
you know to to to think nothing is
impossible and
and just go for it so the combination of
the two you know i can find all the
things that i
at least i see it very inspirational i
love it and the way
three words that you would choose to
describe yourself or anybody would ask
would choose to describe
who is roi eliao
wow it's hard for me to speak on behalf
of someone else
on behalf of myself i would say
a quick learner um
very persistent um
um
in uh social i would say right i really
love people
and interact with people so i i think
that the whole story
speaks exactly to that
yeah exactly
thank you very very much best of luck
with salt security i love the
the company but even more than that i
love your outlook your vision
you the way you were perceiving it it's
amazing thank you toda and stay safe and
stay healthy
thank you very much thank you for having
me thank you